- Hello everyone and good
morning, good afternoon,
or good evening, wherever
you're coming from.
My name is Ato Quayson
and I'm a professor of English
at Stanford University,
and I have the very, very happy position
of moderating this magnificent session.
Let me start over right
away by welcoming you all,
but, and then also by giving
just brief introductions
to the various directors and the speakers.
First, we have Jennifer DeVere Brody,
who is professor in theater
and performance studies
at Stanford, where she serves
as the faculty director
of the Center for Comparative
Studies in Race and Ethnicity.
In other words, she's my colleague.
Hi, Jennifer.
Stephen Pitti is the Director
of the Center for the Study of Race,
Indigeneity and Transnational Migration
and a professor of history,
American Studies and Ethnicity,
Race and Migration at Yale University.
Hi, Stephen.
C. Riley Snorton is the
interim faculty director
at the Center for the Study
of Race, Politics and Culture,
and a professor of English and Literature
and Gender and Sexuality Studies
at the University of Chicago, hi.
Tricia Rose is chancellor's
professor of Africana Studies
and the director of
the Center for the Study
of Race and Ethnicity
in America at Brown University.
Hi, Tricia.
So, we open with Jennifer.
So, Jennifer over to you.
- Thank you so much Ato
and colleagues here.
It is indeed an honor to
be part of this collective
and this conference on racial reckoning.
I'm speaking to you
from the unceded Muwekma
Ohlone native homelands,
an acknowledgement that
only begins to reckon
with the reparations
required to repair the damage
of centuries of racial capitalism
that calls upon us to exercise
in Theresa Montoya's words,
radical vulnerability.
In yesterday's panel,
colleagues spoke eloquently
about the reorganization
of knowledge, power,
Safwat hoopla needed to
transform the university.
As the recent news about the
daughter of the African family
and Philadelphia's MOVE program
whose bones were used
without consent for a lecture
involving my Alma Mater,
University of Pennsylvania
and Princeton University,
often known as the
Northern most institution
that sits on the land of the Linaila Nape,
and also where I was born,
has shown universities have
trafficked for many centuries
throughout the Americas and in Europe
in the bones of the ancestors.
And so we're thinking here
about a reckoning of bones
from the Americas to Auschwitz,
to gynecologist, Marion Sims
and that's a shout out to Riley Snorton
who's written with such moral clarity
about Sims' transgression
with the bones of the dead and the living.
And so, our bodies and
our bones have been used
without consent in the name of knowledge
that benefits what Ferguson
yesterday talked about
as a professional exercise in benchmarks.
Indeed, all the panelists
yesterday shared their concern,
which we're going to
continue talking about today,
about how to work more
ethically and equitably
with the punitive objects and subjects
that the university hierarchies
produce and sustain.
And I think that really is our focus
on critical race studies
and its institutionalization
within the larger
understandings of knowledge.
So, in my nearly 30 years as professor,
having taught at seven universities
in many different departments,
English, African, and
African-American studies,
gender and sexuality
studies, performance studies,
I have often looked to,
not only other scholars
in critical race studies,
which was really organized in the 1990s
by a group of critical
race and legal scholars,
but I've also looked at
artists whose work intervenes
in the restricted
covenants of racial order.
In preparing these short remarks,
I had too many examples
of contemporary scholars
and artists, black and brown,
those who work for civil
rights, feminist, art, act up,
AIDS, anti-war protests,
against the prison industrial complex,
indigenous rights, police
violence, farm workers unions,
disability rights, occupy trans justice,
anti-nuclear protests,
demonstrations against the
World Trade Organization,
the bay areas, people kitchen collective,
I could go on and on,
but to choose from people who are working
to "the motto" of the
people's kitchen collective
here in Oakland, and I
do some work with them,
to feed the mind, nurse the
soul and fuel a movement.
And I'm pointing to them
in part not only because
they do amazing work on
recreating, for example,
the free breakfast in DeFremery,
Little Bobby Hutton park
in homage to the Black Panthers,
but to try to get at this
idea of what kinds of care
or carry tasks that the
university in its Cartesian claims
to specific forms of rational
thought too often elides.
And so I'm thinking a little
bit of Charles Mills' work here
on the racial contract, on
the whole sort of history
that organizes Western knowledge,
that puts those of us who are working
in the margins around
critical race studies
and want to transform that knowledge
in a slightly oppositional
or complicated space
vis-a-vis traditional
forms of understanding
what counts as thought.
So, these academics and
artists that I've mentioned
begin to try to break down
some of those barriers
between theory and practice
and Marxist terms of practice
and intervene in university structures
that institutionalize a
hierarchical division of labor
between scholars and researchers
or artists and practitioners.
Something that the
center where I work now,
for comparative studies in
race and ethnicity at Stanford
has tried to dismantle by asking
practitioners, for example,
working on ethics, race, and technology,
to come into the university and teach us
and get us to think differently
about the knowledge that they produce
in their own spaces of work.
And similarly, in theater
performance studies,
we have tried to tenure artists.
So, what counts as the
book or what is tenurable
begins to be undone.
And I'm trying to talk here a little bit
about the segregation of
faculty, not only from students,
but of different kinds of valuation,
of what counts
as the imaginative creative
dimension of scholarship.
And again, I join a long, long list
where Tim Spillers has talked about this
in her classic essay on
"Harold Cruises: The Crisis
of The Negro Intellectual,"
how is it that we want to
value the different subjects
at different ways of
knowing in the university
that can maybe go against
certain enlightenment legacies
that are race and de-value embodied work,
which is concomitant
with the mind-body split,
where disabled, working class,
female and racialized others
weren't necessarily seen to
be thinking human subjects.
And this matters
because part of the
current racial reckoning
asks us to change the
"face of the university"
and such a shift for me must
not only be quantitative,
but also qualitative.
We must not just change the color,
but also the content of academic culture,
redo the syllabi, reorganize
academic apartheid
to use Dwight Conquergood sprays.
At Stanford, we did just finally
hire two artist scholars,
Yung Jing Lee among them, whose
play, "Straight White Men"
was the first produced
by an Asian American woman on Broadway.
And like Toni Morrison,
we hope she'll be the first
tenured creative artist
in our program.
We can see that also what happens
to the extra diagetic,
I'll call it, labor,
that too many of us
scholars of color ask to do
on behalf of changing the
face of the university.
I'm talking about all of the uncredited,
and unpaid, if you will, labor
to diversify the university.
How does that get accounted for
in questions of who is valued
and what is valued as forms of work
under the university rubric.
We can see that a whole-scale
cultural, economic and
political change is required
to begin to achieve racial
justice in the university.
In my own work, I've
spoken about the difficulty
of having inherited a segregated academy
that makes thinking about
historical connections,
in my case, Blacks and Britain,
I think Noemie talked
about this yesterday,
that made that unintelligible
in the narrow confines
of academic knowledge.
So, again, let us remember
that racial justice
cannot be achieved by numbers
or any one metric alone.
As Jeff Chang says,
"When you choose to fight,
you hope it will not only be
merely for greater numbers,
but rather for more power in those numbers
that can lead away to equity."
So, this is why Adrian
Davis and our colleagues
who just founded a center
similar to the ones
you'll be hearing about
from the other faculty
directors on this meeting
called the center for race,
ethnicity, and equity.
So, it's E2 there at
Washington University,
and this is a new center founded in 2020
and there are a lot now being
founded across the country.
So, our centers that
you'll hear from today
with my colleagues on the line,
we met first as a collective
of directors of such centers
and I think one question
we have for the audience
and we wanna discuss is,
what is really the value of these centers?
Davis notes that without students,
we would just be a giant think tank.
And I wanna just take
a moment to give credit
to the student activism
that helped to found
my center 25 years ago
through a hunger strike
and that continues with the
founding of so many of the work
on expanding questions
of race and ethnicity,
whether that's from SF state
50 years ago, to the present
where we continue to see new groups.
I'm getting ready to close
my comments and in doing so,
I just wanna take a moment
from a colleague we met.
I think Steve was on the line,
all of us at University
of Washington, St. Louis
with Adrian Davis, where Chandra Ford,
who was the founding director of UCLA's
Center for the Study of Racism,
Social Justice, and Health
made the very important point
that when she established that center
on Indigenous People's Day,
she sought to integrate
critical race studies lens
with public health initiatives.
And though I think most of us
here are in the humanities,
I wanna point to the really breadth
that critical race studies can bring
to reorganizing the entire university.
And to also bring up a point Chandra made
where she talks about combating
liberal forms of racism,
which can be overshadowed
when we focus on the
spectacular everyday violence
that we have seen, of
course, really every day.
And especially over the last four years,
if not four centuries,
that if we can fail to interrogate
the power differentials
that organize the university
that are seemingly benign,
but I think no less
pernicious in forms of racism.
So, we've seen a lot of
university administrations
give a little statement
around whatever act of heinous
and spectacular violence occurs,
but really not necessarily look
to how do we change those
institutions in which we exist
whether the police, the
prison, the hospital,
or the university.
To be sure, it appears that
universities across the country
are grappling with these
legacies of displacement
of enslavement and the
nefarious forms of profit,
which have brought them into existence.
And we can think about Ruth Simmons,
the first black woman, president of Brown,
leading the charge to try to think
about reckoning and recompense, sorry,
for enslavement and indigenous
profits at the university,
or even at Stanford, we've
just taken down the sculpture
of our first president,
David Starr Jordan,
who was a eugenicist
who took part in the
racial betterment society,
but the renaming and the removal
of such vexed figures of violence
still leaves us in our centers
vulnerable to displacement,
troubled by remainders
and yearning for greater
equity across differences.
I hope that these opening remarks
that draw from critical race theory,
interdisciplinary studies,
feminist studies, black
queer studies, and the like,
all of my disciplinary formations
help us to sound a call to action,
to mobilize compensatory redress,
to respond to precarious
citizens past and present,
and to reckon in the bones
with racial injustice.
Thank you.
- [Ato] Thank you very much, Jennifer.
Thank you so much.
So, Stephen, you go next.
- Thank you so much, Jennifer.
Thank you for your leadership.
I just admire everything
you've done there so much
in recent years and as
somebody who has been shaped
in some way by the center you run,
I'm just grateful for your vision
that you've brought to
the place in recent years.
So, greetings everybody from New Haven,
the historical and contemporary home
of many indigenous peoples and nations,
including the Mohegan,
the Mashantucket Pequot,
the Eastern Pequot, the Scatter Koch,
the Golden Hill Paugussett, the Niantic,
the Quinnipiac and others where we
in the Yale Center for The
Study of Race Indigeneity
and Transnational migration try to work
mindful of their presence
in its many forms,
contemporary and in the past.
I'm gonna speak in a little
bit of a different mode
than Jennifer just offered
and talk a little bit about
the specifics of our center
as a way to get part of
this conversation rolling.
I direct the youngest center
represented here on the panel.
Since we founded RITM at
Yale in the winter of 2016
and have just completed
our fifth anniversary,
the other centers represented
here are longer in the tooth,
more established than that.
Being established in the second
decade of the 20th century,
as we were, gave us at Yale
the opportunity to think for a while
about what an academic unit
we actually wanted to create
that institutional
contract that Rod Ferguson
talked about yesterday.
And we had some luxury in
building on the great work
already happening at places like Stanford,
Chicago, and Brown,
and being able to alert our administration
as we made the effort to create a center
that they needed to enable our work
in establishing a race study center here
in order to keep step with
my colleagues on this panel
and their places in so many other places.
So, as with every other comparable center
I've ever heard about,
Yale center was a product
of political pressure
as well as hard intellectual work
and compromises with and
by the administration.
So, here's our story,
a small group of faculty
members on our campus,
including me, first began
to meet and develop the idea
of what became the RITM center in 2007,
roughly eight years before
RITM was in fact established.
Those faculty were in departments like
African-American studies,
American studies, history,
women, gender and sexuality studies
and our ethnicity, race
and migration program.
No real surprise that
those were represented.
All of us were faculty of
color, are faculty of color.
All of us were cross
pointed in multiple units
and had interdisciplinary interests
and struggled to meet the needs
and the expectations of our various units.
We were frustrated by
failures to successfully hire,
recruit, and retain faculty members
working in fields like Latinx
studies, black studies,
native and indigenous studies
and Asian American studies.
We all felt that students
interested in those fields at Yale
were intellectually
underserved by our university
in the 21st century.
We all felt anger about the
paucity of faculty of color
on our campus generally.
So, in short, we were unhappy.
We'd watched as valued
friends and colleagues
were not promoted or left our campus
for other seemingly more hospitable
colleges and universities.
And we felt tired in the 21st century,
tokenized on too many committees,
trotted out sometimes as
showpieces when convenient,
conscious that our students
were not receiving the education
that they wanted and needed
and trapped too often in
debates with our administration
that we could not escape.
So, that was the situation
around 2007, 2008.
So, that's still somewhat familiar today,
I'm sure to many people in this meeting,
and it was the situation that led us
to ask for a research and teaching center
that would both first
dignify studies of race,
and intellectual engagements
with core issues in ethnic
studies and related fields
as topics of studies, but
also as prisms and parameters
for approaching these topics.
And secondly, a place that would
provide resources and space
and a hub, perhaps a catalyst
to advance the interests
of members of our communities
and serve as a magnet
for attracting and retaining people
interested in race studies.
So, the second point is important
because we felt fractured
and divided and isolated
in separate departmental
spaces on our campus.
And we also knew
that there were just far too
few of us doing the work.
We were then able to
actually create the center
in the 2015/2016 academic year,
when Yale undergraduates
pushed our administration
to address campus climate
and faculty hiring
and our undergraduate curriculum.
We, faculty members had
this center proposal
that had been sitting
collecting dust in our offices
from a few years before,
and we were already ready
to make that suggestion.
So, we took the center
proposal to our president
and our provost who
approved the general plan.
But I must underscore what Jennifer said,
it would not have happened were
it not for student struggle
and student support.
In my final minute or two,
let me just close quickly
with a few notes about our
focus in the RITM center
and some of our struggles,
just to put these on the table.
First, you should know
that we've focus today
more on graduate students
than on our undergraduates on our campus
as a research and teaching center.
While undergraduates, it
seems to us still need much
that they're not getting,
by comparison, graduate
students have had far less
structured support on our
campus as emerging scholars.
And because we in the center
wanted to shape research,
we've therefore put the
emphasis in terms of our funding
and our programming more
on MA and PhD thesis
and related projects, major projects
than on the support of
undergraduate classroom exercises.
Second, in RITM, as at Stanford,
we've tried to work across
the entire university
throughout our professional schools,
as well as in our faculty
of arts and sciences,
but also in our university
museums and in our theaters
and in another parts of our institution.
This has been rewarding,
but as you would imagine,
also challenging,
and that's worth talking
about, the scope and scale
and how to get that right.
Third, we've tried in our
work to amplify ongoing work
at the university in various
departments and units
while also developing new work
that's not yet able to be amplified
because it doesn't exist yet
in more under-resourced areas.
I'm thinking, for example,
we tried to co-sponsor events and visitors
and efforts through departments
that are already doing this work,
but we've also tried
to bring units together
that don't talk to one another,
or haven't traditionally done that,
and we've tried to focus
attention and resources
on topics related to race indigeneity
and transnational migration
like native and indigenous
studies or Latinx studies
that have had less pull in
established departments.
For example, there is no department there,
there is a department of FM,
so, we tried to support FM
while also putting resources
in developing areas that don't have
institutional support elsewhere.
Fourth, we've successfully
helped to bring undergraduates
to Yale as undergraduate students
and also doctoral students to Yale,
into small departments
over the last five years.
The undergraduates whom
we've helped to recruit
have come in part
through an awards program
that we've run for high school
students around the country
who are interested in our RITM topics
and doing social justice
work in their communities.
And we've been part of
that recruitment process.
The graduate students who come
to Yale at our encouragement
have often come because we
offer them in our center,
a home outside of the smaller department,
and our home is one in
which they can fully engage
topics related to race,
in ways that they may not be able to
in their home department
and our center is a place
where they can be assured
that they will see more scholars of color
than they likely will in
their small humanities
or social science department,
where there are often far too few of them.
So, that's been a method
of recruitment as well.
So, we've had some success in
recruitment for that reason.
Fifth, we've been more
successful, I think on reflection,
I think we've been more successful
at gathering graduate
students across units,
than gathering faculty across units
who don't already know one another.
In fact, we've struggled
with consistent faculty
participation in our center,
partly because faculty remains
so tied to departments.
Our untenured colleagues of course,
need to be present in
their tenuring units.
Our tenured colleagues already
serve on so many committees.
So, our efforts, unfortunately
often just invite more work
from our faculty colleagues.
"Yes, we'd love for you
to do that conference,
just tell us what you wanna do."
Well, that's more work.
"Sure, we can help with that expense,
please fill out this form
and send us your receipt
and so forth," more work.
"Would you be willing to
serve on a prize committee
for the center?"
And so forth and so forth.
Sixth, and finally,
we've managed, I think,
to be somewhat catalytic across campus
in the spaces I've described,
bringing funding and what I do think of
as some kind of dignity
to subversive efforts
in various parts of our campus,
or perhaps they're better
called creative efforts
or efforts at greater accuracy
or something like that
in different departments and programs.
So, while we may not always
capture the attention
of large numbers of faculty,
we have tried to be
strategic in helping faculty
who wanna do interesting
and important things
in ways that aren't being
supported in their units
to do that work.
In fact, we've had some
of our greatest success
in supporting non-ladder
track faculty on our campus
who are working on RITM topics.
We've been able to provide
some research funding
that they wouldn't get otherwise,
we've given them opportunities
to share their research with one another,
and we've organized
writing groups for them
that are often not available
in their home departments.
This may sound like small stuff,
but it actually dignifies
the work of people
who are otherwise being
treated as contingent labor
all too often on our campus and elsewhere.
I'd say the same with
our efforts to engage
with some other people on campus
who may not be at the top levels
of their institutional hierarchies.
Some of our most creative
curators, for example,
are artists scattered
around the university
who may not have the checkbook
that gives them the full
funding that they want,
but that we can bring some of our funding
and some of our support to
help them realize their vision,
particularly visions related to reckoning,
which after all, is the topic
of our conversation today.
So, I'm gonna stop there and
pass it onto my colleagues.
Thanks so much.
- [Ato] Thank you so much, Stephen.
So, Riley, you come next.
- Yes, thank you, Ato and thank
you to Jennifer and Stephen
for their brilliant remarks.
It's such a pleasure
to be in conversation with my colleagues,
the center in race consortium,
and it's my privilege to work
with the incredible staff
at the Center For The Study
of Race, Politics and Culture,
Tracy Matthews, Maryland
Willis, Jacquelyn Gaines,
and Tiara Kilpatrick.
As an opening statement, I wanna
provide some of the context
and a sense of the day-to-day
of the center's activities
as a way to ground some of
the intellectual, political
and ethical work as I see it.
I also wanna acknowledge that
the University of Chicago
sits on the tribal homelands
of the Council of the Three Fires,
the Odawa, Ojibwe and Potawatomi nations,
as well as other tribes.
And as the sixth largest urban
native community in the US,
indigenous people continue
to practice their heritage,
traditions and care for
the land and waterways.
The Center For The Study of
Race, Politics and Culture,
CSRPC, was established by my
colleague, Michael C. Dawson,
professor of political science in 1996.
And from its inception,
CSRPC has been committed
to establishing and sustaining
a space to center and expand
the study of race and ethnicity
at the University of Chicago,
by fostering interdisciplinary,
transnational,
and intersectional research,
teaching and public debate.
So, at the center, we understand
that race and ethnicity
affect every idea and interaction
and we work to foster meaningful dialogues
about the myriad ways race and ethnicity
inform our lived
experiences and scholarship.
The center is committed
to providing funding
and other forms of support
like many of my colleagues
working at other centers
for projects that are initiated
by faculty affiliates,
graduate students, undergraduates,
artists, and residents,
and visiting fellows.
And I'm especially proud that this year,
in addition to our ongoing
artists and residents' program,
which we've been doing in
collaboration with arts
and public life,
that we welcomed our
inaugural practitioner fellows
in conjunction with the
posing human rights lab.
As part of their fellowship,
each practitioner is designing a project
that explores an aspect
of the carceral system.
By doing this kind of work,
we continue to strengthen
community relations
with the south side and Chicago
as we continue to act in
solidarity with local,
national and global struggles for racial,
ethnic, economic, gender
sexual, and social justice.
So, in addition to providing funding
and other forms of support for scholarship
overseeing an undergraduate
major and minor,
hosting residencies and visiting fellows,
sponsoring workshops and working groups,
which include the reproduction of race
and racial ideology workshop,
the race working group,
which is a graduate led
and graduate-only space,
the mass incarceration working group
and the race and pedagogy working group
and the slavery and visual
culture working group,
the center supports and sponsors
a number of public programs
geared toward promoting an
investigation of the ties
between race, ethnicity, and culture,
often in collaboration
with student groups,
other campus centers and academic units,
as well as community-based institutions.
This is the day-to-day work of the center.
And yet we're also ethically
and morally compelled
to be responsive to our
current environments,
to provide forums for
activists and scholars,
to give context and share
strategies for combating racist,
sexist, homophobic, and
transphobic injustice and violence.
Unlike some of the other schools
in the centering race consortium,
the University of Chicago
does not have a department
devoted to the study
of race and ethnicity.
However, through the committed work
of some of CSRP's faculty affiliates
working within the more
than diversity campaign
and in solidarity with years of organizing
from U Chicago students
with U Chicago United
and particularly ethnic studies
now, the grad student union,
and the black grad student collective,
there has been some
progress made on that front,
which allows for us at the
center to begin to engage
in the related process of
imagining a renewed center
that works alongside
an emergent department.
And I'd like to pause here,
but will be happy to return
to some of these issues later,
as I think this moment at
the University of Chicago
allows us to think about
reckoning on a number of registers
and perhaps also to consider
what comes after a reckoning.
Thank you.
- [Ato] Thank you so much, Riley.
So, Tricia, you're next.
- Thank you, Ato.
Thank you, my dear colleagues,
members of the CRC.
It's been great working with you
and fantastic hearing you
here and planning this event.
Thanks for everyone
who's come out on this.
At least in my part of
the country, rainy day.
I'm gonna try to focus my comments
on a broader set of questions and problems
that don't entirely always
dovetail with my own center,
but when they do, I'll
certainly emphasize it.
And that has to do with what I would call
the consequences of the legacy
of the formation of race centers.
All of the centers represented here
have tremendous faculty support
and amazing work comes
out of these places,
graduate student investments,
so on and so forth.
So, I'm not in any way disparaging
that level of intellectual investment.
But what concerns me is the
degree to which that work
is undermined by the very structures
that force us into the
placement that we're in.
So, I wanna talk a bit about that first.
The formation of the centers
that study race and ethnicity
broadly in the United States
almost always emerge
from a student protest
first and foremost.
And everyone here had mentioned
that at one form or another,
either in the past or in the present.
I was like, no, it's an ongoing project,
but I wanna say a little bit more
about what that student activism is about
because it often becomes a touchstone,
but it's a very important
part of the critique
of disciplinary knowledge
in the university.
Eventually, students of
color of various types
come to the university
only in the last 50 years
and they realize that the
structures of knowledge
in fact, are not in any
way designed to shed light
on the histories of the
groups out of which they come.
And that kind of protest is
usually focused specifically
on demanding that the curriculum
provide significant
educational sources for them.
And in addition,
it's a challenge to the
role of universities,
the social protests channels
to the role of universities
in the given town, in a given city
and its role in being a
sort of not in alignment
with social justice
movements in the street
and in the public sphere.
And so, it's an implicit critique
about the role of race in the discipline.
And that's why this notion
of institutionalizing
critical race studies
is such an important part of the framing.
It's not simply to study race
because that is actually going
on every once in a while,
but in ways that was actually reproducing
the very problems that
we're talking about.
Jennifer talked a bit
about this at the outset,
in terms of anthropology
and so on and object.
So, I just wanna really put
the work that we're doing
in the context of disciplines
that are structurally hostile,
even in the cases when you have,
well-meaning faculty members
in those departments,
I'm not making an against
every academic in a discipline
of United States, but I'm more saying
that I think it's really important
to talk about the institutional
tension that's there.
The space of centered on race,
it seems to me are really developed
in the inters disease of
the university as a whole.
That there's a very little
space that is cracked open,
and we endeavor to inhabit
it, to give it life,
to figure out what's needed
in our particular local circumstances.
But that process does
result in a number of things
that I think are exceptionally important.
One is that it's built in fragility
and that fragility is registered
in lots of different ways.
It's registered in terms
of funding and support,
space, whether or not centers
or interdisciplinary spaces can be homes
for tenure track positions
in all or in part,
it's about whether or not it can be seen
as a valuable and important
part of the university
and its forms of knowledge production,
and that matters a lot for whether or not
faculty from other departments
can be involved safely
and professionally, it's understaffed,
and then it's often frankly, trotted out
and this is over and over again
across 50 years trotted out
at the prices of the decade
or the prices of the year
to hold and be the center of discussion.
Now, I will admit at Brown,
I've had tremendous support for
the center during my tenure,
but CSREA has been around
since the mid 1980s, 1986,
and for a lot of that time
had extremely limited support
and was in many ways starved
off the necessary resources
to do a number of the
things it wanted to do.
It however was a very successful incubator
for the ethnic studies
concentration at Brown.
And so that's been very important advance
that happened before,
but the level of work that it
takes to keep this crack open
for all of us is very significant.
And it not only requires the immense work
of our colleagues who donate their time
as Steve was pointing
out to various endeavors,
but it means that those
of us who direct them
aren't simply directing in
a climate of presumed value
and dignity and significance,
for one has to perpetually
explain the value
and significance and why,
even in cases when centers for race
are placed in campaigns for endowments,
which is extremely rare,
but even in the cases when that happens,
one has to explain over and over again,
what one does and why it's
a central relevant issue
and why would any white people
wanna give money to this,
for example, which if I could tell you
how many times I've had that conversation.
So, for me, this means that the reckoning
is not so much about more centered
and more of the repetition of
the structures that we're in,
it's really about a fundamental challenge
to the construction of race
and the marginality of race,
to the thinking and the framing
of the vast majority of traditional
disciplinary knowledges.
And that can't just be adding
on a section in the curriculum
or adding on one course,
it has to be a very significant reframing
of what these disciplines are
about, perhaps a dismantling,
which is what my colleague, Matt Guterl
was talking about yesterday.
But I think this
reckoning can't just be at
hoping students are gonna protest enough
to expand more attention
or that we'll be able to have
a friendly administration
which would be lovely and in my case is,
but what I think the reckoning
really has to be about
is is a real fundamental infrastructural
intellectual challenge to the
whole enterprise to say that
"If you think you can do discipline X
and not fundamentally
think about race, gender,
and sexuality, indigeneity, and so on
as significant parts
of how your discipline
was either shaped or how
it's functioning now,
then you're not doing
the work you need to do."
It has to be that level of
racial reckoning, in my opinion,
otherwise, we will be in
very much the same position,
25 years from now with a next
generation of brilliant people
who will replace my
brilliant colleagues here
and for sure, me, and
they will say very much
the same thing, maybe with
different academic language,
but they'll be in a very similar position.
And that ultimately is
a stabilizing phenomena.
So, that our fragility, our underfunding,
and yet our constant repetition
of protest and inclusion
and so on and so, it's
a dance of repetition
that I think doesn't change the outcomes
in significant ways.
And so I wanna end with a real challenge
that we don't necessarily
wanna blow up our centers,
but there's a sense in which our demise
has to be part of our plan
in that we have to
imagine that departments
can be so fundamentally changed,
that we would be part of that change
rather than keeping this tension
between margin and center
in terms of the disciplines.
So, I'm gonna stop there
'cause I know we're talking a while,
but I'm looking forward to
our conversation as a whole.
Thank you very much.
- Thank, you so much, Tricia,
and to all the panelists.
This has been magnificent.
Now I have a set of questions
to ask to open up debates
and I have the questions here,
but I'm going to pose one
of my own that I fabricated
as I was listening to you guys.
And it has to do with,
to put it very simply,
the problem of proposition making
in interdisciplinary studies
because all these centers
are at heart, interdisciplinary.
Now, what do I mean by the
problem of proposition making?
I am in an English department.
Now in an English department,
and I'm sure that Riley will see echoes
of his own department English at Chicago,
in what I'm going to say,
Shakespearean and what
I'm going to say now
align specifically with Shakespeare
and Medieval studies.
A Shakespearean to make a
proposition on Shakespeare
for it to be salient in the
field of Shakespeare studies
will have to master several languages,
Latin and Greek among them,
will also have to master
different discourses,
medical history,
sometimes music and so on,
but one of this signature
features of Shakespeareans
is that they're etymologists.
They like the diving
into the meaning of words
in Shakespeare.
There's no serious Shakespearean
who doesn't know
something about etymology,
for a very simple and practical reason.
The language of Shakespeare
is 450 years old.
Now, if you shift from the medieval,
and the medievalists are also similar.
If you shift from medieval
studies and Shakespeare studies
to say, post colonialism my own area,
our protocols of proposition
making a different,
they are more advocacy oriented.
They're more shining a
torchlight on inequality
and colonialism and so on and so forth.
Our protocols of proposition
making are so different
that it is not unusual
in English departments
for shakespeareans and
medievalists to think
that they're in completely
different department
than concerns from say, Shakespeareans.
My question is then this,
so this is back to what Tricia said
about we should contemplate
the demise of our,
or the non-existence
of our various centers
of ethnic studies,
what would it take for the
protocols of proposition making
in anthropology, in sociology, in English,
in the various disciplines to admit race
as an aspect of proposition making?
And this is not simply
about looking at race
because you could look at
race and still not change
the way that you make your propositions.
So, this is a question about
intellectual paradigms,
it's not merely additive, it's not merely,
let us talk about race now,
but it's about the more,
so for example, the postcolonial,
I talk about race completely differently
from how a Shakesperean
or even a classicist talks about race
because it's completely different
because the genealogies
of the idea of race
in the classics are different.
What would you,
so this is my invitation for
you to lend your thoughts,
to the problematic of proposition making
in our interdisciplinary race
and equity, CCSRE, and so on,
but in relation to how our
protocols of proposition making
might make sense within
the individual disciplines.
So, this is my question to start with.
We can start from the
same order of speaking.
So, Jennifer can respond.
- Just briefly and I do think
it's a related question,
my father was a social
scientist and he used to say
that my questions began where his ended
in terms of being a quantitative person.
And my greatest, I think
discussion that we would have
precisely this question was
when he was writing along
chapter on Gordon's
theory of G in psychology
and had the good fortune
to put in at least,
and of course this was taken
up and this was a racist idea.
Gordon was a eugenicist
and he said that had he not
been in discussions with me over time,
that that would have been
a "irrelevant detail"
to explaining how that term worked.
And similarly, even with
Shakespeare studies,
I know, the work of Kim Hall,
we were talking about this yesterday,
even in terms of etymology,
Peter Stolley Ross was actually
my dissertation advisor
who was a Shakespearian, very
much interested in entomology,
but where that takes you is
not just a classical myth,
but to very key terms such
as what is a blackamoor.
And so we are always, I think,
already engaged even the very notion
of an English department with England
and the English language.
If you really get into
it in medieval studies,
this came up yesterday,
Geraldine Hangsworker,
that really opens up
again to a global world
in which race is produced discursively.
And I think it was Noemie that yesterday
was talking about the fact
that who is asking the question
can sometimes change the very notion
of what is important to know,
which is what I was trying to say.
And I think that it speaks also very much
to everything everyone has said here.
And Tricia saying that what would happen
if we completely changed what
we think a university is for
whom does it serve, what is this about,
why are we engaged in this kind of work?
And we've seen this with the increase
of the global university.
And I think that that's
why that term reckoning,
which is also talking about
the distribution of funds
and sources and value is so important.
Thank you for that question.
- [Ato] Thank you, Jennifer, Steven?
- This is a great question, thank you.
There's so much to say on this.
I think I'll just try to
keep it relatively simple
and say that I think it is,
to me, I always come back to
words like, dignity and value,
which Jennifer and Tricia,
I think Riley and everybody
uses very commonly.
I think to me, it's about
enfranchising points of view,
dignifying those points of view,
allowing formations and
understandings to take center stage
in university-wide and
societal conversations,
but actually minoritize or
diminish the prominence of
historically rooted, but
narrow ways of thinking
about problems that are
very much departmentalized.
I'm fortunate at Yale that I
actually work in a university
that we have certainly
have a lot of problems
around interdisciplinarity and
recognize interdisciplinary,
but we have some very wonderful
interdisciplinary programs
and they have prominence.
And I often say that
many, I'm a historian,
and one of my appointments is in history,
but I often say that many
of our best historians
on our campus are not in
the history department.
And I'd like to see
our students in history
actually work with them as well,
even as they're getting their degree
and their credential in the department
to which they were admitted,
I'm thinking mostly of
graduate students here.
So, I think that centers
can work in a lot of different ways.
I'm all for the revolution
and hopefully working for it.
And I think that the idea
of the withering away of departments
is absolutely something to be
anticipated and pushed toward.
I also think that we make
small gains in departments
by dignifying people's work,
who actually very much
identify with their discipline
and wanna see their future in a discipline
in ways that I may not be the thing
I think of as most productive.
And yet we're talking about
the politics of small numbers.
There's relatively few of us.
And so I wanna see our center, for example
working with and helping
move forward conversations
that may be very disciplinarily bound
and that I think may
not be the longterm ways
in which we wanna go,
but that actually, I think do bring value
because I want that particular
faculty member to prosper
in their local department.
And I know that if they're prospering,
they're bringing a couple
of students along with them.
So, I think we can do that work,
which may be additive
and not revolutionary
alongside doing the revolutionary work,
which is more about privileging
other ways of knowing,
other methodologies, other connections
that are different problems of proposition
as you were putting them.
And I think it's the
challenge is to be open
to doing all of those
kinds of work at once.
And so, anyway, that's where
we are, I think, on our campus.
And it leaves us sometimes
unclear about next steps
and priorities, because
there is so much work to do,
but we don't wanna
foreclose what may seem like
the more cautious or more
conservative approach,
because it's not radical
or revolutionary enough.
We wanna think about
ways to do all of that.
- [Ato] Thank you, Stephen.
Actually, there's a line that you used,
which I used to think a little bit more
is enfranchising different points of view.
You said this in your response,
enfranchising different points of view,
a whole lot of weight can
be put on the question
of how to enfranchise
different points of view
as an aspect of proposition
making in the discipline,
because it's true, in
English literary studies,
they have historically not been very open
to enfranchising minority points of view
of which they are mainly
even in the dominant specs.
So, the question
of how to enfranchise
different points of view
is really important.
Riley, please.
- Thanks and I was also really
struck by that formulation.
In some ways, it also
underscores how I think
about what it means to
do work at the center,
which is that we are a space
for Maximalist approaches
to race and ethnicity,
that there are many
ways through many modes
that people are engaging in
these questions critically.
To that and in concert,
I hope with the comments
that Jennifer and Steve have already made,
I'll just add that some
part of your question
is also making me think a little bit
about some of the fields that I work in,
for which the matter of
institutionalization is not settled.
To be working in the
field of trans studies
is not really seen as
having a particular way
in which a proposition might be made.
And so I'm also deeply interested in,
or have been hearing echoed
throughout the course of the last two days
the provocation from Stewart Hall
about what it is, for him,
what cultural studies would do
for example, to a
discipline like sociology,
which is in some ways it
was to cannibalize it,
but in so doing to make it anew.
And I think often,
sitting and being trained
in inter disciplines,
the work then becomes,
it's obviously always
still rife with power,
but it's also about a
project about legibility
and audiences.
I think as Jennifer mentioned as well,
who are you talking to as
another note to Noemie,
but I really appreciate the
question as an invitation
to think along these ideas.
- [Ato] Thanks, Riley, Tricia?
- I guess I just have two additions
to these wonderful remarks.
The first is that disciplinary boundaries
are somewhat arbitrary.
They have historical formations,
but sometimes you have different
propositional formations
in the same discipline,
and they're not necessarily
limited because of it.
What that means is that disciplines
are political skirmishes.
Really they're the result of
winning political skirmishes
and as such, they shouldn't
be treated as gospel
and they should be understood
as being transformational
or formation of one form or another.
So when you say can the
protocols and proposition making,
that might come out of a
critical race studies framework,
where can they be?
Well, they can be in a lot of
places for the reasons I said.
The second thing is that,
I totally wanna support
this initial point,
which was, look, you do both.
And you do all you have
to do at this moment.
And we've been very fortunate
to recruit some amazing
scholars on race to Brown
in the last five to eight years
who've increased the ranks
of what was already a really
amazing group of people.
So, I wouldn't say, "Well,
we just gotta burn it down,
do rehiring and don't put
anybody in the discipline."
I'm certainly not saying that,
but I just wanna illuminate
that when we accept the categories,
when we accept the disciplinary structures
and we allow the power that
they hold over resources,
there's no question.
I don't think anybody on
our panel would say like
"Our history department is in
any jeopardy of disappearing
any time soon."
Not to pick on historians,
but I could say a number of disciplines.
And that fact is a really
important part of the problem
and the circumstance that we have.
So, what I'm really asking us to do
is be not so much radical only in action,
but in thinking about knowledge production
so that we don't end up here again.
And by here, I mean that
amazing work is being done
but as a number of people mentioned,
there's fragility around getting tenure.
There's fragility about
what kind of work matters.
There's fragility around
what kinds of arguments
you can make about race
and expect to have the
same type of career.
And all of those things
are part of the issue
that brought our centers into
existence in the first place.
So, you can't have it both ways.
We can't have it both
ways, it seems to me.
And I just wanna remind us of that
as we think of how we want our centers
to function going forward.
- Wonderful, Tricia.
I like your line,
"Disciplines are products
of political skirmishes."
That's a good line.
- [Tricia] Copyright for
later, you can have it.
- There's always a food fight happening.
No, these are all wonderful comments.
Now I'm going to go to
the prompt questions
that I have here and the one
that fascinates me most is,
actually, I'm doctoring one of them,
which is what has been the success,
or how do you think you
might operationalize
placing race and equity studies
on the entire undergraduate curriculum?
So, everybody is interested,
has to do something about it.
Do you think this is just utopia?
Or at Princeton some years ago,
they nominated Anthony Appiah's
book on cosmopolitanism
that everyone entering Princeton
that year had to read it.
Now Appiah's theory of cosmopolitanism
is what one might describe
as a gentleman's theory
of cosmopolitanism.
It is not anything that would,
I think, it doesn't
poke anyone in the eye.
He's himself is such a gentleman.
So, but that's what the students read.
And so they all came out
feeling completely cosmopolitan
but not in ways that would
unsettle the very principle
of cosmopolitanism as such.
So, my question is how might
we persuade our universities
to make race and equity
a general concern across the campus?
So, that's my question.
So, starting with Jennifer again.
- Okay, and I hope we will
get to lots of questions too,
if there's some from the audience,
I guess I would just say that again,
what does it mean to read?
Because there are I think four books
for the Stanford students this year,
one of them, I think "Call Me By My Name."
And they have over the years
had Neil deGrasse Tyson's
work and so forth,
but how are those texts
being read and interpreted,
rejected or valued?
This is then at the heart of how also,
I think we need to transform
not just what we teach,
to go back to your example
earlier of Shakespeare
where you can open that up to
questions of race and equity,
but it's also how you teach
and what that syllabi is,
what's the method and what ultimately
are you trying to change?
And is it then also not
just about how we read
or what we read, but in what context,
and again, I'll just
say for whose benefit,
because I think too often,
even the way those books are selected,
have to do with still the larger problem
that we have inherited of
the university as a space,
Oxbridge, of educating a liberal citizen,
citizenry always already
self-segregated previously
before we had EOC or ways of diversifying
when schools had their
quota of Jewish professors
or blacks like Dubois
were not allowed to teach
at University of Pennsylvania.
The very idea of the university student
is one that I believe is
still imagined to be ideally
a certain type of person.
And so that whole idea of what
is the liberal education for,
I mean, I don't wanna
go to metal with that,
but I think it's relevant.
Again, whom do we imagine we are serving
and how those books would
even be interpreted?
- And then also the
relationship between university
and community, because
often universities are like
they're elite pods.
The elite pods of innovation
and some university department
have no interest in what is
happening in the outside world.
So, also the relationship
between what we do
and the communities beyond.
- That's why (indistinct)
has a model tradition
of community engaged learning,
and we have students do an internship,
but of this particular kind
where they're prepared
to think about questions
of community-based research and solidarity
before they even go out
into the "community spaces."
- All right, so, Stephen, do
you have something to say?
- I can answer this
question quickly, I think.
How could we have these
conversations carefully?
I mean, I think that that's a
really an important principle.
Expertly, I think is another one.
They can't be had on college
and university campuses
and rambly in ways without careful thought
and also in ways that are,
and this is really important, I think,
cognizant of the differential ways
in which people enter and
experience these conversations.
I mean, for so many of
our students they're,
I mean, college is so different
from for most of them,
for what they grew up with
and those who we would
wanna be very cognizant
of supporting in these conversations
can oftentimes take these
conversations as very difficult
and very hard.
And the lack of support
of these conversations
for people who experienced
these issues directly
and disproportionately
can be very challenging.
So, those would be at least just so,
without trying to get too
much into the details,
those would be at least three principles
that I would wanna suggest
ought to be guiding any discussion.
- [Ato] Wonderful, Riley?
- Thanks, and I am really just struck by,
I think, what some of the great principles
that have been put on the table
and I'll add, I think just one more thing,
which is really that,
and the conversation,
intellectual conversations about race
are happening in places
in which they are also
being actively disavowed.
And so it's also about
providing a way of seeing
that what we are doing is engaging
in racialized forms of thought
that may be absented of,
what we see as a legible
understanding of a racialized body
or how race plays out
in terms of discourses
of race relations.
- [Ato] All right, Tricia
and then we'll open it
up to the panelists.
- Yeah, yeah, sure.
Super, super quick.
I think the way I would encourage us to do
critical race studies
intervention in the curriculum
is to remind our students
and the disciplines to remind themselves
that they were formed
under a white supremacist,
colonialist infrastructure
and ideological framework.
All of them.
And that that's not a sub piece
of the puzzle off on the side.
It was a fundamental
component, not the only one.
Not even necessarily the super
most, most important one,
although I think it ranks up there
and that that as a mode
of self interrogation,
you have to be willing
to interrogate the self
that's a Western philosophical framework
from Socrates in the first place,
you must interrogate the self
in order to grow, to learn, to transform.
So, it wouldn't just be about
adding courses or readings,
it's about asking the disciplines
to do the true self
interrogation that's necessary
to understand why race
is a central element
in the formation of everything
in the ways in which these ideas
that were not about race
on their explicit terms,
were all about race and control and space
and who was a problem
and who needed to be
excluded from governance
and who didn't,
what mattered in the
constitution and what didn't,
so on and so forth.
And the principles were great,
we just added black people.
We messed up the first
time, we added them later.
No, no, that's not what happened.
So, that's what I think is
more important than anything
in terms of really to making
the change that we want.
- Wonderful to hear.
Wonderful, you all.
So, now the questions,
are we going to Meghan?
Are you going to read them
out for us or should I?
- [Stephen] I can do that.
- You'll do, all right, please.
- Let me pose this question to all of us.
We have a question from
this app from an instructor,
I think who is asking a general question
about requirements in their fields.
And the specifics are
about language requirements
that are required for the
achievement of a degree
that strike this person
as perhaps outdated
and potentially a mechanism
for predetermining
the direction of the discipline, I think.
So maybe what the question
is on the table is,
how should people be
thinking about these things
that may be ostensibly race neutral
in a particular discipline or department
that actually do have the
effects of perpetuating
ways of approaching topics
that either mischaracterize
or fail, even to recognize the
topics we're talking about.
So, I just asked the question,
so I'm not gonna answer it.
I guess I'll turn it to any one of you
who wants to take it off.
- Well, I guess maybe I'll
just say super quickly
that when I was in graduate school,
one of my colleagues petitioned
to have Jamaican Creole,
which she was studying Caribbean count
for her "foreign language."
She herself was actually West Indian
and so these questions of,
again, the scholarly languages,
I'm not saying don't know them,
but they have that tradition that Tricia
just laid out for us so nicely,
again, of what are the languages to know.
And those two came us out
of a particular hierarchy
or where we thought scholarly thought
and in what language
scholarly thought happens.
- Thank you.
I think the matter of language acquisition
and Jennifer, your
comments really got me here
is that really it's supposed
to signify one of the tools
that's needed to get at the thing
that you want to get at inside
of your particular training.
And so I also was
trained in media studies,
a fairly new 20th century
invention of a discipline
wherein things like knowing code
was a way to suffice in
your language requirements.
So, I think these kinds
of questions as you put it
that are seemingly race neutral,
but also get at a larger
philosophical orientation
of what it means to be graduate curriculum
in which the case has to be made why X
in the service of what
you are aiming to do
both in terms of your question,
but also in terms of the
container of the program
that you happen to be sitting
in while you do your work now.
- Ato, do you wanna take a shot at this?
I mean, you may-
- Don't have anything to add.
- Steve, you go ahead too.
- Please go ahead with the questions.
- I wonder if this also
relates to another question
that was asked,
which is essentially what
students might be doing
if they're working in a
field, in a department,
in a so-called discipline
in which the issues
that we've been talking
about centering race
haven't really made it to their fore.
Any thoughts for any
students in the audience
who may be struggling with
these very specific questions
in their own departmental home?
Whether those are undergraduates
or graduate students?
- Can I jump in?
- Yeah, yeah.
- At Toronto, I run
the Center for Diaspora
and Transnational Studies.
A new, so, we set it up,
it's now like 15 years old.
And so outside the University of Toronto,
before I moved, I jumped around
and could go to Stanford.
And this question came up all the time,
"Why diaspora studies?"
And one of the things that
I pointed out to my students
is that every respectable
institution these days
has diversity, they'll
call it different things.
They have a diversity office
and they're interested in diversity.
So, that for example, banks,
many banks have found out
that as new immigrants arrive
and settle, new immigrants
are very interested
in putting down roots by buying homes.
So, every bank has a diversity officer
whose interest is in
targeting marketing products
to newly arrived immigrants
and some banks are more
successful than that.
But as someone who has
done critical risk studies
cannot only shape the
direction of these products,
but also give the bank a
higher as it were consciousness
on these things.
Let me jump to another completely
ridiculous example, FIFA,
the football Federation
is very much about,
they say so themselves, so we
can take them on their word,
equity, the distribution of
resources to various leagues,
to historically marginalized
populations and so on.
What better than someone who
has done critical race studies
to go and work at FIFA and tell them
that you're looking at the
thing completely wrong,
and from my tree, in other
words, there are many,
and the more we produce
students who are savvy
and understanding of critical race studies
and the more impact that they
make in different industries.
And so on, the more value
will be given to our fields.
So, this is one answer that
I used to give to my students
in Diaspora and Transnational Studies.
They need you, just tell them you are here
and they will hire you.
- Yeah, I'm wondering if I
could jump in for a second, Ato,
and just ask some of my colleagues here
a couple of questions
about what they imagine
would be some important
new areas to move in
in terms of their centers
or things they have on tap
for the people who joined us today to say,
"What are we gonna do with
the space that we have?"
Maybe it's programming for next year,
maybe it's envisioning something
five years down the road,
maybe it's challenges, whatever it is,
but I think, what are we going to do
that we're either excited about,
that we think is going to change
the landscape of where we are
or what kinds of things
do you wish you could do
and do you just can't
see your way right now?
But I think it's important
to imagine a future together
and anyone, Jennifer, Riley, Stephen?
- I can jump in.
This is an opportunity
to say how excited I am
to be working with the colleagues here
on this centering race consortium
that was funded by the Mellon Foundation.
So, one thing I would say very positively
that I think we're really
excited about doing
is looking for ways to
partner with other colleges
and universities to expand
the sense of community,
the good ideas, the
opportunities to think together
about issues that are just so critical,
that we all agree are critical.
There's just not enough of us
to go around on any given campus,
and we need one another's
support and good ideas.
We need to be able to create
opportunities for one another.
We need critical feedback from one another
that we may not get on our home campuses.
So, the chance to work with
the colleagues on this call
and with others around, on these campuses
is really exciting to me.
And we're hoping to be able to do this
with faculty involved,
with students involved,
with artists residents involved,
and so I'm really excited about that.
One thing that I'm concerned about,
and I don't know if any of the rest of you
struggle with this is that art
center has gotten pulled in
on our campus to institutional efforts
related to diversity equity and belonging.
The DEID efforts and some
ways we wanna be there,
because I do think that the
intellectual work that we do,
the credentialing and amplifying of work
in these areas as critical
areas of research and teaching
does translate to questions of climate.
There's a relationship
between ennobling these fields
and who gets hired and who
stays on a given campus.
So, there's reasons why
we wanna be involved in this work.
At the same time, there
are sets of challenges,
I think here when academics like me
and I think like all of us
get pulled into these conversations,
into committees about
tone setting on campus,
best practices on campus
that are not related
to the research and
teaching and other things
that I think we're primarily focused on.
So, I'm just flagging that as
an area of challenge for us.
And I didn't know if anybody else
had any thoughts about that.
So, I've given you the positive,
which is the consortium,
that's one thing and then
I'm raising the question
of if and how our centers
have a role to play
in these broader university efforts.
I don't wanna be an HR
specialist, for example,
and I feel sometimes like I
do get pulled into that stuff
and our center does and if
we get pulled into that,
we're not doing other important
work that we could be doing.
So, if that's of interest,
maybe somebody wants to comment on that.
- Jennifer or Riley, anybody?
- Well, the thing is
that one of the reasons
why Stanford, I'll have to
talk about Stanford, Jennifer,
and correct me if I'm
wrong, 'cause I'm new.
I'm only two years at Stanford.
Why the recruitment and
retention of faculty of color
has been a problem is
specifically because,
not just because of the tone, Stephen,
what you just mentioned, the tone,
but also because for some reason,
the numbers don't, they
never are able to grow
because people come and then they leave.
So, our being pulled into these things,
distracting though they might seem,
sometimes almost inescapable,
because we want to increase the density
of faculty of color, but
to increase the density
and the numbers, we have
to somehow contribute
to creating the environment
where the faculty of color
arriving sees themselves in it.
This is especially crucial
for pre-tenure faculty.
So, senior faculty like
me, I'm at home everywhere,
it doesn't really matter,
but I can imagine if I had
arrived as a pre-tenure,
I would have been scared for
the rest of my seven years
before I got tenure at Stanford,
because the history of the
tenuring of a faculty of color,
let's assume the English department
let's put it very
diplomatically, it's sub optimal,
and this is putting it diplomatically.
So, in a way, you almost cannot escape it.
- I think you've put
it in managerial terms
and that was my gesture
towards the global university,
but like University of Chicago,
we at Stanford suffer from
not having a department,
for example, of African and
African-American studies
before I too was hired as a full professor
over 10 years ago at Stanford,
I was a full professor
in African and
African-American studies 100%.
So, the kinds of reach
and interdisciplinarity
and centering race that we've talked about
was very much a given and
understood and valued.
And we are like University
of Chicago, fighting
and as you well know,
Ato, 'cause you've been
a wonderful part of that.
Not only to have a department
and maybe a department of ethnic studies,
I don't know what the
landscape will look like,
but also an Institute
because it's at Stanford
that institutes have great value.
And literally in terms
of resources and scope
and hiring more people
so it's not the same few.
the numbers of black faculty at Stanford
have remained statistically
flat since the 1980s.
And I think that is in part
because we've invested in fact
too much in junior people,
which is continuing to happen,
who are brilliant and wonderful,
but don't necessarily have the wherewithal
to compartmentalize and know the landscape
or understand even necessarily
what a university is about.
That's a huge transition
and we're not taught in
graduate school to do this DEI
or DEP work.
And so it's, again, the
burdens of representation
that fall too often on the
bodies that always already
are laboring at a certain
kind of personal expense.
So, we need to do more
of that structural change
that everyone on the
call was talking about
to really make it better labor conditions
and really change the
face of the university.
- If I could jump in, Riley,
unless you were about to jump in.
- Go ahead, Tricia.
- Oh, okay.
I just wanted to piggyback
for a second because I just,
my favorite thing about Zoom
is that you can like
quickly surf the internet
before you say something.
So, I wanna say that
Stanford's black faculty
are 2% of the faculty.
So, let's just think about the
numbers we're talking about.
So, when we're saying, "Well, they leave,"
it doesn't actually matter.
You can't fix the climate with 2%.
- And for black women, it's 1%.
- Oh great, it's 1%.
Well, the internet needs to go catch up.
That's why I acknowledged I
went to the Stanford website.
So that in case it was incorrect,
I wasn't gonna be held responsible.
But that's an unbelievable
failure in numbers.
It's easy for me to say that
'cause I'm not in Stanford,
but this is extremely important.
Of course there's gonna be climate issues,
I'm sure when they're
calling Stephen to say,
"Can you discuss it?"
It's all about we can't
afford to lose anymore
or whatever the problem may
be, but this is a real problem.
I mean, like we just can't stand around,
act like we're all doing all of this
and everyone isn't doing
race work either necessarily.
So, when you bring those numbers down,
you have to bring them down even further.
And I don't think,
I just wanna comment on
Steve's really important point
about diversity work,
that climate stuff is the university's job
and there are lots of talented people
who do this for a living and
they need to be invested in
and all the faculty and staff
need to be participating
in what to do with that.
Certainly there's some
intellectual work that overlaps
and dovetails with that
and I get called to do the same
thing you're talking about.
Some of my own research on
systemic racism overlaps.
So, I can just stay, do my research
and it still has a Diablo effect,
but if not what you're doing,
you shouldn't be called in there.
But just one last thing on the positive,
'cause I love Steve is positive, negative,
I have to end with the positive
'cause my negatives outweigh
the positives all the time.
So my positive is not only
that this has been super
exciting for the four schools
to think this way,
but that we've really been empowered
to create cross-university curriculum
and cross university teaching.
And I think we should,
I'm empowered and inspired
and our grant empowers
us to really do that.
And I think that's super important
because not only will that
help our various one to 2%
on being community,
but it will also just create
a collective knowledge
and expand all of our
work much more quickly.
So, this is Zoom, the sort
of crisis of the pandemic,
creating a virtual world as the norm
and the context of the grant
and the geniuses who
were speaking yesterday
and those of you who were
in the audience here,
this is a really exciting moment
where we can take this work,
make it public, make it share
and push forward.
- Let me say something
else that's exciting.
I made this reference earlier
to the politics of small numbers.
This is the flip side of that 1%
that we're talking about at Stanford,
or I often say like,
I'm one of three Mexican
American faculty members
I know at Yale and I'm
married to the number two.
And so there's only one
who I'm not married to
on our campus.
So, anyway, so small numbers.
But the flip side of
that is what we do know
is that in working with
students, with colleagues,
if we can make differences in their lives,
if we can help to bring
that one extra person
to our campus or help them to
get that seminar paper done
or get that master's thesis
or that doctoral dissertation done,
keep that colleague who
was hired on our campus
but was considering a move,
if we can make a positive
addition to any of those moments
and those people's lives,
this can have remarkable
effects on our fields,
on the departments or units
in which they're working,
on the students that they're
working alongside with,
whether we're talking about a student
or we're talking about a faculty member.
We work with far more than
small numbers in our centers,
that's certainly true.
But when we succeed individual
by individual by individual,
I think we can have really
important multiplying effects
that ought to be recognized.
And so that's one of the
things that makes me happy
because it's in this work,
there are moments where you feel set back
by the larger atmosphere
in which we're working.
I could have told stories about that
as I know everybody on
this talk could have,
and yet at the same time,
we are able to hold onto,
I think these experiences
with small groups of people
or even with individuals that we know
really do have made a difference
and just looking at you,
Jennifer, Riley, and Tricia,
knowing some of the
faculty you've supported,
the students you've supported,
it's amazing to see the
work that you've done
with those people over time
and the way in which
your investment of time,
your trust in their projects,
the leadership you've given
really has made a really
important difference
to people on your campuses, but
also well off your campuses.
- I just saw a question here,
Riley, sorry to interrupt,
but it's an important one, I think.
It's from one of the participants.
"Is the consortium open
to HBCU collaborations?"
And this is a question for you guys.
- That is the hope we were charged
by Mellon with these four institutions.
But I think our goal is to
work not only with HBCUs
and indigenous colleges,
community colleges,
which there is a push
to make those free now,
which would be wonderful, but
other kinds of institutions,
I think Steve mentioned museums,
places where folks are incarcerated
and education is happening.
So, I think that there is,
and that's a lead in for tonight's
wonderful connected event
to Reginald Dwayne Betts
and his interview with E-viewing tonight,
but that we really hope this is the seed
that's going to grow and connect.
And we absolutely welcome partnerships
and our we'll be actively
seeking them out.
I was gonna say that earlier
when Steve was saying,
what are you looking forward to
and I'm saying, looking forward to working
with even more folk.
- So, Riley, sorry to
have interrupted you,
I thought that was an
important question to bring up.
So, I interrupted you Riley, please.
- Yeah, no, I think Jennifer
really answered that
and also gave me another occasion
to say that I hope that you will join us
for the CSRPCs's annual public lecture,
which is also the closing plenary
for this racial reckonings
in the future of the humanities conference
and just about an hour from now.
So, I hope that many of you
will be able to come back for that.
But I also was really
just sitting with Steve's
and I think this is
perhaps also inclusive of
what does it mean to think
about opening the consortium
or collaborating across a whole host
of different institutional sites,
which is that I was really like,
yeah, often when we talk
about grief tragedy deficit,
we think about it as
cumulative and compounding,
but we also might want to attend to
the ways that there are other
kinds of collective energy
that can have a cumulative effect.
And so I really heard that inside
of what I think is the real aim
of the work that we've been doing
at the centering risk consortium
and the real desire for it as it grows
over the course of the next several years
and hopefully beyond.
- Well, last remarks.
I think we have some two minutes to go.
So, final remarks,
30 seconds each starting with Tricia.
- Okay, couple of quick
points, ideas really matter,
and this work, no matter
how marginal it may appear
can have an out sized effect.
And I have a tremendous sense of hope
when I look at my students
and my colleagues and all there is,
and I just wanna push us forward
and see as many obstacles
as we need to see
to make as much space as possible.
And we hope that we'll
work with many of you
in the audience today to make
that happen in the future.
- Jennifer?
- I put it in the chat already,
but I do believe that
there is joy and strength
in this kind of collective work
and to know that you're
not the only one anywhere
laboring singularly,
but rather we're all
looking to do this work
and all of it really does
make a difference in matter.
So, I'm grateful, thank you.
- Riley?
- Yeah, no, before joining or
getting into graduate school,
I was an organizer and there's
so much of what it means
to direct the center where
I feel like I'm drawing
on every available toolkit here,
precisely because there are so many people
who rightfully have a stake
in the center's business
and activity and so I'm really grateful
for the opportunity to
work with those folks,
as well as to work collaborative
across these universities.
There is a lot of work to be done
and I think the centers and the CRC
has been a great site
from which to think about
doing the good work that's available.
- And Stephen, finally.
- Yeah, I just wanna thank everybody.
I mean the struggle is long.
We all are running centers
aware that we inherit struggle
that is decades old on our
campuses and beyond our campuses
and in the broader educational system.
And I think we're at an important moment
as we work together and
collaborate, hopefully,
with people who are witnessing
and in the audience today
to think about changing higher
education at this moment.
There's a lot of work to do,
to catch up to the realities of the world,
to serve the people that we wanna serve
and to be agents of change
in the ways that our centers,
but more broadly, our campuses
ought to be agents of change.
So, thank you all.
- So, thank you all.
this has been magnificent,
I've learnt a lot.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.